como podemos esquecer que estamos
completamente do o fez uso
o ser humano está ao contrário tem
estado a evoluir como espécie humana
guerras e conflitos entre povos e nações
violência criminalidade e intolerância
isto é o que temos estado a assistir se
a um nível mais global até as
organizações tão ao contrário o seu foco
tem sido em lucro
este lucro desmedido é em resultados
será que esse é o caminho é por aí que
temos que ir
estamos completamente desconectados
enquanto seres humanos quando peço às
pessoas para irem abraçar umas às outras
ainda por cima aquelas os quais
supostamente deveriam o dizem que são as
pessoas que mais amamos nomeadamente os
seus pais seus irmãos há uma tremenda
dificuldade em tocar em olhar nos olhos
em abraçar o outro porque será
estamos muito decidi conectados mesmo
devemos olhar nos olhos tocar o outro
até nossa linguagem está o contrário
vejam reparem que nós dizemos os
precisamos através da linguagem
aquilo que não queremos que aconteça
por exemplo alguém que diz pra outra
alguém cuidado cuidado ao destino das
cargas que pode cair
é isso que nós queremos que aconteça eu
posso mudar a minha linguagem e dizer
manteiga tentou diz o times das cargas
que chega às bancas em se sentem que a
vibração é diferentes neste tipo de
comunicação é uma comunicação mais
positiva com enchentes em
ele influencia o nosso sistema cultural
as nossas células
a forma como interagimos com as pessoas
têm gostado acumular culpa e temos pedir
desculpa desculpa para retirar a culpa
não é o orgulho é o ego que sobrava lés
sempre aquilo que é a nossa verdadeira
essência
estamos também ao contrário de várias
outras formas
temos o ser humano tem estado a
manifestar quatro principais emoções são
o nosso maior veneno e aqui agora é
importante referir sobre as doenças não
é que é
é o que nós temos estado a assistir o
último momento o nosso corpo está a vir
a trazer mensagens para nos lembrar
através de sintomas dores e doenças
o quanto nós estamos desequilibrados
psicologicamente e emocionalmente
espiritualmente
não é normal na história da medicina e
moçambique
temos jovens e adultos entre os 35 e os
40 anos a terem ataques cardíacos há
algo de muito estranho
enfim e muitas outras doenças que têm
estado a a manifestar o hiv e sida é é
uma epidemia que está de facto é
continuamente a prevalecer no nosso país
e os números tendem a aumentar com
tantos projetos tanto dinheiro que
movimenta neste país por causa do hiv e
sida tantas intervenções abordagens
diversificadas abordagem de gênero
sociológica até os setores da educação
é da justiça da saúde intervém certo não
está a faltar alguma coisa eu acho que
se perguntar será que estamos a ir à
raiz da questão porque estamos adultos
com formação universitária jovens e
adultos às poréns continuamente a
comportamentos de risco em termos
sexuais
a degradação ambiental é outro exemplo
porque nós estamos ao contrário o lixo
que transborda nas cidades deste país
é um belo exemplo do lixo e terra o que
nós vimos acumulando dentro de nós
vermos quem é afinal a pessoa mais
importante da sua vida merece isto como
foi possível termos chegado a este
estágio
este desequilíbrio profundo
o ganho o grande vilão de tudo isto tem
uma única palavra com quatro letras é o
medo vivemos numa sociedade cheia de
medos
ele está por todo o lado está dentro das
famílias está nas organizações está em
todo o lado
temos medo da morte mas será que estamos
a viver a nossa vida em pleno aqui agora
no presente temos medo de falar
este é um dos maiores medos que nós
temos a seguir ao da morte é o medo de
falar e expressar o que não vai ocorrer
nos vai na mente e no coração na alma
que será de onde vêm estes medos todos
será que nós nascemos com medo das
chamas comer
o quarentão a nossa verdadeira essência
do qual nós estamos profundamente
distante a nossa essência e amor nós
vibramos nós tínhamos e vibramos
precisamente numa energia que oposta do
medo é a energia do amor à criança
quando nash eo exemplo da manifestação
de amor próprio
a criança é alegre é livre espontânea
ela fala de si ela não julga os outros
ela é destemida não tem medo nenhum ela
questiona ela olha nos olhos é amorosa
toca abraça isto é manifestação de amor
primeiro amor próprio e depois
incondicional eu só posso amar os outros
quando me a mesma
o amor é sem condições
incondicionalmente o que acontece então
para nos tornarmos estes adultos todos
desequilibrados algo acontece pelo
caminho então é precisamente nos
primeiros anos quando a criança começa a
ser abusada formalmente emocionalmente
psicologicamente com as primeiras
palavras a receber os primeiros nãos a
ser impedida de exercer os seus
verdadeiros direitos enquanto criança a
ser impedida de falar e se expressar de
dizer que a cidade tem
não mexe aí cala a boca tasso castigo tu
és preguiçosa é feia é burra
isso é abuso emocional e este abuso da
origem aquilo que se chama vergonha é
uma das emoções mais freqüentes na
criança
e é precisamente a vergonha e perseguir
a culpa
infantis estão na origem da maior parte
das nossas adições adição óculo às
drogas ao sexo
o vício do jogo as compras está na
vergonha e culpabilidade infantil tanto
a criança vai recebendo tudo isto e vai
começar a afastar se da sua essência que
é de amor para dar lugar a todo um
conjunto de emoções negativas a medos
tanto para a lenda viu da vergonha e
culpa a um conjunto de outras emoções e
agora importante fazer esta pergunta pra
todos vós refletirmos aqui alguém nestas
nesta belíssima sala que enquanto
criança não se tenha sentido um só
triste insegura rejeitada
ansiosa carentes
carente de afeto do toque de atenção
aqui alguém se houver por favor do
levante o braço duas pessoas
estranho não é fácil estamos mesmo ao
contrário
como resultado de tudo isto a criança
começa a interpretar estas emoções como
eu não sou bom o suficiente eu não
presto
eu sou um fracasso
ninguém gosta de mim e estas crenças
tornam-se a sua própria identidade
a criança vai do facto começará com o
cheiro ea tornar se ídolo xeneize jovem
e futuro adulto com estas crenças dentro
de si
acreditando que esta faz parte da minha
identidade eu sou do fato aquilo que os
outros dizem que eu sou
de tanto repetido
e portanto eu tô num adulto oxi cheio de
medos inseguro e não vejo completamente
imperfeito e que por isso torne um
código pendentes
o qual dependente é aquela pessoa que
porque não tem amor próprio precisa de
ter constante validação externa dos
outros para que gostem se aquele bem
atenção importância para que sinta
valorizado amado
então é pessoa que está sempre a fazer
tudo pelos outros para ajudar o outro e
pelos outros
muitas vezes não se respeitando
não se amando independente é
perfeccionista assunto constantemente sé
a responsabilidade pelo como os outros
pensam sentem e se comportam é tem muita
dificuldade em ver não em colocar limite
para se processou outros é dependente
emocional de uma série de outras
características como então nós podemos
reverter este quadro
como podemos de facto que o cheiro
o crescimento só pode ser de dentro pra
fora do individual para o coletivo
eu preciso primeiro de autoconhecer me
iniciar a minha viagem interna de
autotransformação então este se este é o
convite que eu faça a todos vós e eu
começa com auto observação constante de
mim mesma e auto aceitação incondicional
de tudo que surgir na minha mente
emocionalmente aceitar esse é o nosso
lado sombra
todos nós temos um lado sombrio lado
luxe andemos com os dois lado a lado
o fundo da baliza um sonho investimos
constantemente a culpar os outros por
aquilo que estamos a sentir
ninguém coloca sentimento dentro de nós
nós é que nos permitirmos sentir desta
ou daquela forma
o segmento vem de dentro para fora nunca
o contrário como na prática isso pode
isto pode fazer uma mudança profunda que
é importante fazer a nível dos sistemas
de educação incorporar para uma
abordagem holística do ser humano não
mais uma abordagem fragmentada
nós não somos um só corpo físico e
mental
nós somos emoções coração e temos um
espírito uma alma para alimentar esta é
uma abordagem holística podemos nos
espelhar na filosofia pedagogia waldorf
conhecida a nível mundial para podermos
melhorar os nossos sistemas educacionais
os próprios professores nós não
precisamos de professores estejam a
repetir o que aprenderam a produzir o
que aprenderam a 20 anos atrás
não é não de uma forma como de alguns
dias profundamente autoritárias nós
precisamos de professores inspirador
professores de facto estimulam os pais
estão desesperados
precisamos ajudá los rapidamente se com
projetos ea estratégias que utilizem o
que visem melhorar a sua capacidade de
educacional né
ué chamada parentalidade com gente
positiva para terminar é importante
dizer que nós temos 100% do valor tal
como somos estamos não precisamos de um
diploma de uma casa de um carro ou de
uma roupa xpto para sermos partirmos
valor e sermos quem somos
portanto homens acima de tudo conheço
uns a maior parte das pessoas não se
conhece e por isso têm dificuldade em
aceitar se a mars o autoconhecimento é
extremamente importante
assumo a responsabilidade por todas as
escolhas que fizerem não existe certo
nem errado existem apenas lições que nós
tiramos elevado
conosco aprendam a viver no presente
sinto me profundamente cada pessoa cada
planta que encontrarem é de momento o
resgate do amor próprio
é uma questão de saúde pública quando
governos comunidades e nações grupos e
indivíduos compreender isto o planeta
está curada
[Aplausos]